there is an election in Georgia tomorrow
it's the special Senate runoff election
to determine will Democrats have a 50-50
majority needing Kamala Harris to be the
tie-breaking vote or will Democrats have
a 51-49 majority in the Senate the race
is in Georgia between incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock and
challenging Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker a former president
Barack Obama you know the guy Obama that
guy he was in Atlanta over the weekend
campaigning for Raphael Warnock you
really have to see this Obama's really
good at this
crushing Herschel Walker for his
unintelligible rants of late including
one in which he talked about what was it
vampires and werewolves take a look at
this
every day he comes up with something
every day
[Applause]
since the last time I was here
since the last time I was here Mr Walker
has been talking about issues better of
great importance to the people of
Georgia right
like whether it's better to be a vampire
or a werewolf
[Applause]
true
that I must confess I once had myself
when I was seven
then I grew up right
[Applause]
in case you're wondering by the way Mr
Walker decided he wanted to be a
werewolf
which is great
as far as I'm concerned he can be
anything he wants to be except for a
United States Senator right
that's the critical part
[Music]
but then he admitted
that we've never actually met right
[Applause]
that's typical of Warren but I'm sorry
if Walker regularly telling stories that
are impossible
[Music]
now listen this would be funny
if you weren't running for Senate
that's that's exactly the point and as
I've said before listen it's all fun and
games right Trump running for president
in 2015 2016.
if you had a Republican party that was
more like the Democratic party in which
such an obviously unqualified buffoon
didn't have a shot at the nomination we
could all laugh at the entire Trump
thing he never would have been the
Republican nominee he never would have
become the president of the United
States
that's not the situation we have in the
U.S unfortunately now Rafael Warnock
also spoke I mean it was a rally for him
after all and let's take a look at a
little bit of that
If we're honest I believe in my soul
that Georgia knows that Georgia is
better than Herschel Walker
let's hope
Georgia
Georgia welcome
you
you deserve a senator
who cares enough about the people to
actually know the issues
you or at least an issue if not the
issues
[Applause]
who actually lives in Georgia
is that too much to ask and as we
recently found out of course what was
suspected appears to be true Herschel
Walker really lives in Texas and that's
where he declares homestead exemption
and it's a whole other story in and of
itself we're down to the last few hours
if you live in Georgia make sure to vote
we'll have results tomorrow night